do you
sometimes pinch yourself yeah all the
time every day I wake up and go how are
we here how has this happened
why has this happening he's allowed this
to happen you know it just does not make
sense and how is everybody so scared
when not a single piece of science
backs up the inclusion of anyone that's
gone through male puberty into women's
sport as being fair we've got 18 studies
in the world the last came out of Brazil
in September of last year one of the
biggest and that showed even after 14
years of reducing testosterone we still
had no parity between people that were
male or female there were still hardly
any loss of Advantage so you know the
truth is that they are male body then
that will never change their biological
sex will always be male no matter how
much testosterone they reduce no matter
how much plastic surgery they might
choose to have and again that doesn't
happen in sport they don't have plastic
surgery they don't have genitals removed
you know and in a lot of cases they try
to reduce testosterone for incredibly
short periods of time uh like Leo Thomas
you know with the nc2as Leah was asked
to reduce her testosterone nibbles to
tend animals of testosterone per Lisa
well that's ten times what I have and
that was only for one year
I mean so the the difference is just
ridiculous that person goes from being
460th in America not in the world in the
world they would be not in the top 2000
in America 200 to being number one and
beating three American silver medalists
in the space of a year
so I'm in a very mediocre male athlete
becomes a very elite female athlete and
all those Elite female athletes have
spent 10 years of their life making huge
sacrifices I just expected to step aside
it's funny you say that because we just
had the comedian Simon Evans on the show
who he in his latest show he talked
about uh having problems with his
testosterone levels and he had to get
testosterone replacement and when he was
at his bottom he he qualified to compete
in a women's competitions and you're
just going this doesn't make any sense
it makes no sense and it's also a bit
like you know like boiling an egg so
once someone whose mail's gone through
puberty you can't unboil that egg right
so reducing testosterone doesn't make
any difference and it might mean you
don't get any bigger or any faster but
then it's all relative to how much
training you do anyway so if you or how
much injury you've got all sorts of
different variables you know that are
involved in someone's physical
performance and and whether they're you
know a scale of one 10.
um and yeah just suppressing
testosterone in no shape or form you
know makes it Fair competition Sharon
and you've mentioned about the science
and we've touched on it a little bit so
let's do a deep dive into it what is the
difference between someone like Aaliyah
Thomas and someone like O'Reilly Gaines
okay good good knowledge I like yeah
um so Riley and and Leah tied for fifth
place and and that's where Riley's got
all this bravery from because she was
asked to literally not accept her Trophy
and was told that the trophy could go to
Leah and Riley would have to wait for
hers you know and and I think she and
I'm so proud of her for doing that
because it's really hard as a competing
athlete to come at this beginning of
your career when you can be blacklisted
so bad to go forward in your career I
mean the University was horrendous it
blackmailed all its athletes who were
being asked to train change next to a
six foot four biologically male with
full male genitalia and we're told that
they would be sent to a psychiatrist if
they complained that's what the
University of Pennsylvania said wow yeah
and that's like so that's the stuff they
used to do in the Soviet Union is like
if you don't agree with us you go to the
the psych Hospital yeah that's insane
seriously insane it's so depressing that
that was what came out of America that
you know it it really is and so Riley's
been very brave to come forward and to
speak
um
the difference at Olympic level in sport
is between about 10 and 30 so something
like middle distance running is is 10
percent
uh weightlifting is up there at 30
percent so the more explosive an event
is the more the difference between male
and female biology something like high
jump long jump quite explosive about 20
22 a male of equal weight
will hit 160 harder than female and
that's on to a female bone structure
Which is less dense
women have a bigger Q angle because of
the size of our hips so that means that
we hand up with six times more knee
injuries and things like football
because we obviously have this angle but
it means that a male have more ability
to put power through their legs on
things like sprinting on striding on a
bike in particular it's a big Advantage
so these are all things that reducing
testosterone makes no difference to
whatsoever
so it's um it's massive you know when
you think that
um the nine percent that these German
women meant that they were unbelievably
dominant to the point of 92 of all the
European medals
and not 10 is the lowest that we've got
you know presently between male and
female performance
um yeah I mean it's it's catastrophic it
means that half the length of the pool
and Olympic medals are won by hundredths
of a second
so and also as well there's a lung
capacity issue as well yeah lung
capacity hemoglobin levels hands feet
you know Leah Thomas six foot four huge
great hands huge great feet those are
your paddles so you know all of those
things yes there is the odd very tall
female but it's you know six foot four
in swimming for a man is fairly average
that's not average for a woman the women
is about six foot we're tall breed I
mean each sport let's be honest you've
only got to look at the Olympic Games
you know you don't get six foot four
gymnasts no you don't get you know four
foot six basketball players or
volleyball players so so to be the best
in the world your physiology has pretty
much got to be right to do that Sports
um so yeah swimmers are fairly tall but
we're not that tall you know women are
on the whole about five I'm five ten so
5 10 5 11 6 for most Sprints or female
sprinters will be around that
um distant swimmers can be a little bit
shorter but the guys are often six four
six five six six
foreign